PROTECT PEOPLE IN FLORIDA.
>> Sean: GOVERNOR DESANTIS WILL
JOIN US IN A MOMENT.
FIRST LIVE FROM MARTHA'S
VINEYARD FOX REPORTER SARA
CARTER.
DID THEY WELCOME YOU?
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE A FOX
NEWS MIC FLAG?
THAT MIGHT BE TROUBLE.
THEY MIGHT THROW YOU OUT.
>> Sarah: IT'S ALL OKAY.
THEY WELCOMED ME.
I SAID I AM WITH FOX NEWS.
THERE WAS A VARIETY OF OPINIONS.
ALL IS QUIET ON MAIN STREET IN
MARTHA'S VINEYARD?
>> WE TALKED TO PEOPLE WHO HAD
A DIFFERENCE EVER OPINION THAN
THE ONES WE SEE.
THESE WERE TWO LONG TIME
RESIDENTS OF MARTHA'S VINEYARD
THAT ARE ANGRY AT THE HYPOCRISY
OF NEIGHBORS AND THEY SUPPORT
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS.
>> WERE YOU SURPRISED WHEN
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS DECIDED
OKAY, I WILL SEND 50 OF THE
MIGRANTS WHO VOLUNTEERED TO COME
TO BOSTON, TO COME TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD?
WERE YOU SURPRISED WHEN THEY
ARRIVED?
>> NO, I WASN'T.
I REALLY PRAISE HIM FOR DOING
THAT.
IT WASN'T A STUNT.
THE MEDIA IS SAYING IT'S
A STUNT.
HOW DO YOU GET THE ATTENTION OF
THE ADMINISTRATION AND OF HARRIS
OF WHO IS IN CHARGE OF THIS.
>> IS SHE A GOOD BORDER CZAR?
>> IT'S A JOKE AND EVERYONE
KNOWS IT.
>> I THINK WHAT HE DID WAS GREAT
FOR THE COUNTRY TO GET THE
CONVERSATION OUT THERE.
>> TELL THE TRUTH?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE ANYTHING THAT
COMES OUT OF THE ADMINISTRATION
ANYMORE.
>> HOW DO YOU THINK THE PEOPLE
IN TEXAS FEEL THAT ARE GETTING
THOUSANDS OF THEM COMING IN A
DAY?
WE HAD A LITTLE TASTE WITH 50.
>> SEAN, WHETHER THEY AGREED
WITH GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS OR
DISAGREED WITH HIM, EVERYBODY
THAT I SPOKE WITH HERE TODAY
SAID THERE WAS ONE THING THAT IS
CERTAIN:
THE BORDER AND IMMIGRATION IS
A HUGE PROBLEM.
IT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
IT NEEDS TO BE RESOLVED AND
NOBODY WAS HAPPY WITH WHAT T